after spending a romantic night together
simon and valeria are in a car accident
and she is captured by those who would
transfer her heart into the girlfriend
of a powerful man today on sunday
recapped i'll show you the marked heart
from netflix
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
chapter one
happiness is not round the series begins
with a happy couple in a car called
simon and valeria
they are very much in love
but they experience a car accident
and cement arrived to save the woman
however she soon realizes that she's
been captured to become a heart donor
weeks before we see other lovers called
camila and zacharias who are at their
wedding but the bride has a heart attack
and the doctor tells her that she needs
a heart transplant as soon as possible
although she's been on the waiting list
for three years the husband tells you
not to worry because he'll take care of
it in the present we see that those who
capture the girl are people who work for
zacharias and want her to donate her
heart to camilla simon wakes up after
the accident and he realizes that his
wife is not there
he steals a car and tracks her with a
cell phone meanwhile valerian her
captors are detained by some soldiers
she tries to escape while the men are
dealing with the authorities however
they kill the soldiers and go after her
at almost the same time the husband and
the police track her down but the evil
ones find her first and take her away
the police catch up with simon and think
that he's the one who has killed the
soldiers they arrested without listening
to him while valeria is taken into the
operating room chapter 2
a guest inside my body the doctors
extract valeria's heart while the police
realize what's happened although they
lost track of the villains they send
simon home where the family is
devastated the evil men deliver
valeria's heart to zacharias and the
transplant begins
shortly after we see that the transplant
was a success
while simon is desperate since the
police have not found his wife days
later we see the valeria's children miss
her a lot while her husband has
hallucinations of her in the morning
simon receives a call from a stranger
who gives him the possible whereabouts
of his wife
he goes to the police and they find her
in a lake
later the inspector tells him that maybe
they gave the heart to someone else to
live meanwhile camille asks a friend to
investigate whose heart she carries
inside her chest while zacharias
continues with his work guiding the
candidate cardenas through elections
chapter 3
the search camila and simon meet by
coincidence in a concert where he helps
her take a picture
then an accident takes place and
everyone has to leave
simon escorts camilla safely out of the
place
zacharias arrives and they both thank
simon later simon discovers a document
that says his wife had some tests done
he goes to the clinic and they give him
the complete results
he realizes that she was pregnant so he
has one more reason to take revenge
since the police have not solved
anything
that night camila's friend tries to find
out who the donor was
zacharias talks to her and tells her
that valeria doesn't need to know who
she was since she could get sick from
thinking about it
the friend decides to not continue with
the investigation
meanwhile simon disguises himself and
searches the underworld
he meets the villains who kidnapped his
wife but none of them confess anything
and they beat him up a little so that he
doesn't hang around in their area
chapter 4
that heart should never have been yours
simon sees a photo of valeria which
camilla took earlier he lets the girl
know that she was his wife because of
this camilla sends the photo to his
house
the next day simon thanks camila for the
gift and wants to pay for it but she
tells him no
they agree that he'll pay her by
teaching her how to make pizza
later during the training camila asks
him about his wife but he tells her that
he prefers not to talk about her
the next day camilla goes to a shaman
while simon finds a clue about a girl
who might know something
the shaman tells camilla that the heart
she carries inside should never have
been hers
she has hallucinations and escapes from
there going to a lake chapter 5
the organization
camila's friend pulls her out of the
water and takes her to the hospital
since she's very upset with what the
shaman told her
meanwhile simon manages to approach the
suspect he found a girl named carla who
does not want to tell him anything at
the same time zacharias runs into the
leader of the gang he hired to find his
wife's heart called sarmiento who has
forced him to work with him since
cardenas must be the president and they
must be united
the next day carla decides to help simon
she takes him to where everything with
his wife happened
she explains everything she saw and that
she only knows where one of the doctors
who did the transplant works
simon goes there but only gets the
number to schedule an appointment
later simon and camilla finish their
pizza session but they get caught up in
the rain and end up having sex since the
girl has feelings that have come from
her new heart
chapter 6
no loose ends camila and simon regret
what they did and the girl leaves
without saying a word
at night zacharias tries to approach his
wife but she rejects him since she
remembers what she did with simon later
simon finds the doctor although he runs
away
the police get involved but the villains
find the doctor first and get rid of him
in a plane in mid-flight
camila goes to simon's house for a
camera that she forgot
she meets simon's children
she gets some kind of memories that her
heart sends her from that special place
simon returns her camera and tells her
just what exactly happened to his wife
to which camila is speechless
chapter 7
a pivotal moment camila and simon
continue talking although she does not
say anything about having received a
heart transplant they also talk about
feeling a strange sensation since
they're falling in love but both know it
isn't right the police arrest carla they
tell her what happened to the doctor so
she mentions another name of another
doctor who is also there
zacharias makes camilla's mother a
partner of cardenas to make him look
good in front of the press camila
realizes the date to valeria's
disappearance is the same day that she
received the transplant
she suspects that she has the girl's
heart
later she sneaks into her doctor's
computer and confirms her suspicions
chapter 8 is my husband guilty
the villains have linked carla to the
doctors they follow her and finish her
off
at the same time camilla goes to simon
who tells her that they are meant for
each other but she stops them and tells
them that they should never see each
other ever again the police try to
uncover the truth while simon finds out
what has happened to carla
he sends the children to live at one of
his friends houses since he'll be safer
there
at the same time camilla confesses to
zacharias that she already knows about
how he got the heart for her transplant
chapter nine we are here to change your
life
zacharias convinces kabila that he
doesn't know anything
although they can't talk to the police
either since they would be the main
suspects he tells you that it'll take
care of everything
we see that simon's daughter samantha
begins to have a relationship with a boy
named tomas who has business dealings
with toxic substances provided by the
villains who captured valeria then the
men ask tomas for some money he owes
them
they capture samantha until he pays them
everything while simon and camilla meet
again
but they only kiss and the girl runs
away
chapter 10 the terrible truth tomas is
getting the money together while the
villains are desperate so one of them
starts to kiss samantha but tomas
roommate defends her with a gun
he kills one of them and the girl takes
another gun and kills another because of
this the last villain gets distracted
and they end him too
at that moment tomas arrives although
everything is already solved
the boy in his room may run away while
samantha returns home without saying
anything to her father cardenas and
camilla's mother get married
sarmiento pressures zacharias to make a
deal which involves the future president
while camilla hires a hacker to get
information from her husband's cell
phone
she finds out that her husband is
responsible for everything
chapter 11 the insider camilla confronts
zacharias and he confesses but tells her
that he did it because he loves her
meanwhile simon pretends to be someone
else to get closer to the villains the
villains and simon go along with a man
who knows tomas so he tells them that
that night he will play at his bar
later simon is told that his children
need him
he reflects and decides to stop his
revenge and return home camilla goes to
look for simon at his home where she
sees that he's devastated that he calls
those who killed his wife monsters
one thing leads to another and they end
up having sex again
however when she's taking a shower simon
comes in and sees the scar in her chest
asking her
if she got a heart transplant
chapter 12 the scar the girl can't stand
the pressure and without answering at
all she loses consciousness
simon takes her to the hospital
zacharias finds out that cardenas fired
him since he yelled at him once before
although zacharias doesn't really care
since he's only interested in recovering
camilla's love
the villains capture tomas but he
doesn't want to confess who killed the
other villains
simon tells everything to the police but
they tell him that he doesn't have
enough evidence later cardenas is
convinced that he needs zacharias while
camilla is handcuffed at the hospital
her husband arrives and the police tell
him that they're under suspicion simon
also arrives and accuses the couple of
having his wife's heart chapter 13
the next victim
zacharias is an expert with his words
and he makes use of his verbal skills to
get rid of the police since they have no
proof meanwhile the villains get
samantha's number and ask her to go with
them or else they will kill tomas
at the same moment another the villain
says that they urgently need an organ
and they think that simon's daughter
would be the right candidate the police
go to the location of the other doctor
but he hides very well
at the same time simon asked camila for
explanations
she tells him that she did not know
anything at the time
so she tells him everything she found
out since
although he's still
very upset samantha goes to the place
they told her to
waits for an opportunity and unties
tomas
they try to leave on a motorcycle but
one of the men discovers them and
captures them zacharias meets with
sarmiento but they don't know that simon
records them in disguise
while they say that they want to stop
everything that's happening at all costs
shortly after they tell simon that his
work is done
but before he leaves he notices they
brought a girl and he realizes that it's
actually his daughter that they want to
steal organs from her as well chapter 14
the confession since the villains don't
need tomas anymore one of them takes him
away to finish him off but simon arrives
and saves him
to try to save samantha the two follow
the villains meanwhile camilla is with
the authorities confessing everything
about zacharias
simon and tomas enter the villain's base
and the father stops the surgery
the police also arrive and they attack
each other from both sides they capture
two of the villains but shortly after we
see that the inspector was working with
the bad guys
since he kills one of his companions in
order to free the other villains
later camila goes to simon's house and
tells them her whole story
the children hate her and leave
but simon understands her and they hug
although she can't bear the guilt and
also leaves in the middle of everything
that's going on cardenas ends up winning
the elections
zacharias and his people celebrate
at the same time they arrest the
inspector since the policeman he
supposedly killed managed to live and
told the truth cardenas rejects
sarmiento's help
so he threatens him and leaves
the next day zacharias is told that they
finished off camilla so he screams
blaming sarmiento however we see that
camilla faked her death and changed her
identity to juana marquez simon and his
children have forgiven her and helped
her to escape with her new name
meanwhile zacharias uses his influence
to get sarmianto arrested believing him
guilty days later sarmiento's contacts
locate camilla and they send the
evidence to her husband end of season
one
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
the recaps the best mystery series on
netflix thanks for watching